ولكن ما هو العالم أحادي القطب
بغض النظر عن كيفية تزيين هذا المصطلح ، فهو موجود فيه
يعني في النهاية في الممارسة
واحد فقط هو مركز واحد للسلطة
مركز واحد قوة قبول مركز واحد
حلول
هذا هو عالم السيد 1 صاحب السيادة وهذا
قاتلة في نهاية المطاف ليس فقط
لجميع من هم داخل هذا
أنظمة
ولكن أيضا للملك نفسه لأنه
يدمرها من الداخل
هذا لا علاقة له
الديمقراطية لأن الديمقراطية
تُعرف قاعدة الأغلبية عند أخذها في الاعتبار
المصالح ورأي الأقلية
بالمناسبة ، يتم تعليم روسيا لنا باستمرار
الديمقراطية ، ولكن أولئك الذين يعلموننا بأنفسهم
لسبب ما لا يريدون التعلم
الشؤون الدولية بشكل متزايد
الرغبة في حل مشكلة
على أساس ما يسمى السياسية
انتفاع
على أساس السياسية الحالية
الظرف وهذا بالطبع في غاية الخطورة
ويؤدي إلى حقيقة أنه لا يوجد أحد
أشعر بالأمان أريده
الإجهاد لا أحد يشعر فيه
الأمن لأنه لا أحد يستطيع
الاختباء وراء القانون الدولي
خلف جدار حجري مثل هذه السياسة
هو بالطبع الحافز للسباق
اتضح أن الناتو طرح أسلحة
قواتهم المتقدمة لنا
حدود الدولة ونحن بدقة
الوفاء بالعقد ، نحن لا نرد عليه
هذه الإجراءات أعتقد أنها عملية واضحة
تمديد الناتو لا يوجد لديه
المواقف تجاه تحديث التحالف نفسه
أو لضمان الأمن في أوروبا
على العكس من ذلك ، فهو استفزازي خطير
عامل يقلل من مستوى المتبادل
الثقة ولدينا حقوق عادلة
من kryon اسأل ضد من هو
التوسع و
ما حدث لتلك التأكيدات أن
من قبل الشركاء الغربيين بعد
حل حلف وارسو
أين هذه العبارات عنهم حتى الآن
لا أحد يتذكر روسيا دولة بها المزيد
من ألف عام من التاريخ وعمليًا
كانت دائما تتمتع بالامتياز
اتباع سياسة خارجية مستقلة
لن نغير هذا التقليد
و اليوم
[موسيقى]